all right Monica
Monica where'd you grow up where are you
from originally Mandeville Louisiana
and had a great childhood
um
father had air conditioning business and
mother ran it with him so very quiet
life you know nothing
nothing to say of it you know just live
the good life and across the lake skied
in the lake in the river
played golf tennis anything you know
rode horses all my life sounds great
yeah I was a barrel Rider seven years uh
number one in state so I'm a
perfectionist and
um you know it doesn't matter what
anybody else is doing it's about me what
I want to achieve I'm a goal writer you
know that's it really what do you want
to do when you were a kid when you grow
up I wanted to be an oceanographer
believe it or not
but uh I was very smart graduated when I
was 16. left my house at 16 and
graduated college 19.
and business and finance
uh was putting together graduated
college at what age 19. it was almost
20. yeah
wow I just like had a photographic
memory don't anymore but I did you know
uh
I've started uh taking over companies
and restructuring them with someone else
who was a little older than me but um
he had the money to do it so that's what
we did and uh then he started laundering
money for the mob believe it or not I
don't know if I can say that or not but
he had 39 counts of bank fraud I ended
up marrying him and uh
FBI came to my house and said Miss Kirby
FBI you either leave him or we're going
to indict you to so I left
it was kind of crazy I've lived many
lives you know that was when I was young
but
um we traveled I've traveled all over
the place and then started traveling out
the country I guess when I was in my
middle 20s
and uh don't like to travel anymore it's
just not that glamorous you know do you
have children I have five children I had
I have two I have three baby daddy if
you want to say as they would say but I
had one child when I was 19. I was 20
when I had her and then I had my son
Christopher with the person I was
talking about and uh then I had three
with my husband and he's been gone for
17 years he was a monster
um two of my boys have passed away and
so I kind of lost it you know my all my
children are raised though and have you
lose two of your sons one of them was
Peter was 24 in Texas he stole from the
drug dealers they killed him and my son
my oldest son was 30 and he was killed
in a car accident sorry so within a four
or five year
time so it's been really it's not fun
and then my husband molested both of his
children our children so it's been a
nightmare you know but
we get through it you know it's not ever
going to go away but you have to learn
to make it every day the best that you
can and you know I cry every day I just
keep it to myself you know
don't let anybody see that side of me
not that it's a weakness but it's just
private you know
nobody knows your pain
um what I've learned living here I came
up here because I was sick of living
with these snotty people in Mandeville
and Covington they just Nouveau rich I
mean even the Silver Spoon ones like the
entitlement is just so ridiculous
nothing was ever given to me I've made
everything happen I had a construction
company a mortgage company a brokerage a
real estate company and I commissioned
off every one of those you know so I
look at every angle to try to make money
and then got out of that when it's
Insurance restoration got out of that
decided to be a nurse became an RN with
a bachelors in science and I studied to
be um to do hospice work that's what I
wanted to do 17 years hospice and then
open to sitting service so my clients
were my hospice patients so I did very
well my house is paid for everything's
paid for
um I do what I drugs over here I don't
bring it home with me where drugs are
always a part of your life no never
never ever I never did drugs at all
until I got sick with the leukemia the
doctor gave me everything and I said oh
this feels good takes away a little the
pain in the head and little body pain
um gosh let's see it's been
since 15. chronic myeloid leukemia is
livable it's almost like an immune
system you know uh break down it's too
many white blood cells uh flood Your
Body Blast you
um they thought I had Mono at first I
used to run 10 miles a day believe it or
not five in the morning five at night
I'm crazy and he's either up here or
down here I don't know it in between you
know like somebody else I know huh like
somebody else I know probably yourself
huh that's right yeah it's hard to um
I'm a Loner too I don't I don't
understand people very well like I just
I'm not trying to be mean or anything
it's just that I can't
I don't have a job I can't do this I
understand pain and I understand
but I I've learned this what I my pain
is not their pain and if you lost a
child and I lost a child you might be
suffering a whole lot more than me
because you don't know how to handle it
different I handle it differently but
I've learned to humble myself
uh living over here I just left on the
fluke I just one Saturday I left and
never went back
and
my son found out where I was and I've
been here almost 10 years now I go back
and forth and everybody knows where I am
now but I just left because I had enough
of everything and I was I started
getting sick with headaches and seizures
and I have a it's not a tumor it's
adhesions in my left lobe
um caused from being hit by my husband
with the back of a rifle hit me so hard
over and over when I left him that's the
only thing I can think of that happened
so it causes me to have seizures it's
just sitting there you know
uh can't take it out it's too dangerous
and my son says you already touched in
the head mom so don't do it so the drug
you started after which event or was it
just a series
um I guess I started heroin I started
doing you know prescription drugs and I
did those for like four years this is
all after maybe losing your sons uh
right after uh
you know uh Katrina hit and my husband
had died but I had already left him just
uh the stress from Katrina but I was in
pain and stuff so the doctor had
prescribed all this so I guess I started
using prescription drugs in 2016. and
then I started
2000 2018
I started using heroin because
it was costing me when I ran out of my
prescription it was costing me like six
and seven hundred dollars a day
to feed my habit because a 30 oxy is
thirty dollars then you got to pay
someone to go get it and all and give
them some and you know it's just
outrageous so that someone said heroin's
cheaper so that's how it started
snorting it and then one time my dealer
gave me black tar I know I couldn't
snort it so of course I shot it and I
knew I would like it you know that's why
I didn't want to do it but uh of course
I liked it and I've never been to rehab
and I'm not going to rehab when I quit
I'm going to quit on my own
I'm strong enough to do that you just
got to go through the pain you know
you're gonna quit and get on methadone
methadone's just as bad Suboxone is just
as bad so then I'm addicted to that
legally you know I I think that people
don't
I can't judge anybody but I think that
they use their weakness people tend to
keep they're weak you know I'm not going
to be like that I can't do it I don't
judge them but whining and complaining
is not going to get you anywhere so I'm
just a hard ass I guess you know but I
don't um someone asked me if I do heroin
yes I do well well you know God doesn't
like you to be a prostitute and do
heroin and God doesn't judge me either
so you know don't talk to me about all
that you don't know my relationship with
him and that comes up often you know
what are you doing out here you don't
look like you just belong outside and
doing this job everyone will ask me that
it's not your business you know but if
you want to know well let's sit down you
know but it's it's hard
um
it's hard I guess it's harder to make
anything I think that everybody does has
an addiction to something whether it be
shopping sex
drugs but people so just say people in
Mandeville and Saint Tammany the rich
people they're really not rich they just
rich in their house drive a nice car but
they can't afford any furniture you know
and they have twenty thousand dollar uh
rental you know lease every month I
don't believe in that you know I'm just
I'm very tight with money but not here
whenever I make I give away half my
money I have money in the bank across
the lake oh anytime but I don't take it
out
it's just
I write down what I need and I get it
and I do it every day you know you're
living where now I live uh in Mid-City
and it's very humble it's one room
and uh he doesn't have a bathroom or a
kitchen or nothing you know you have to
go Three Doors Down to the bathroom but
I don't it really is like my son came in
this was dump you know
it doesn't matter where you know I keep
it clean it's spotless I painted the
walls the floor everything gives me
projects you know I'm always doing
something it's not you have to be humble
in your life and
it wasn't that I wasn't humble because
I've had to work for everything it's
just that I took things for granted like
a washer and dryer hot water a bathroom
to yourself you know a nice clean bed
and clean clothes not always did you
have that in the last 10 years like when
since I've been here you know sometimes
you and everywhere you go you got to pay
you know pay the house and pay this and
pay that I never knew that I didn't know
go to Walgreens and you have the
deodorants locked up the hell you know I
never even heard of this are you happier
when you lived your life where you were
writing high and achieving a lot of
things oh of course I love I love that I
mean
I loved to achieve you know and set my
goals and you know yes but I also like
this better because
I get to see that people were all human
you know we we all got here from some
way you know and people I don't think I
ever judged like why are they on the
corner you know panning for money and
they have this big house these people
don't have that they really can't get a
job they look at them they're you know
they live on the street
do I think some of them choose to yes
you know they could go home but they
don't want to Pride you know pride is an
older man going to go home and live with
you their sister they smoke crack you
know
you know and just you don't really know
where people come from and how they got
where they get you know and where they
are
and drug dealers you can't really blame
them what the hell are they supposed to
do they've been taught that all their
life you know their daddy sold drugs
their Uncle sold drugs how else are they
going to live and how else is going to
go get a job at Home Depot and bring
home what 200 300 a week they make that
in a day
and same here you know I average out
about 850 a day and I don't work every
day you know I'm going to top out at
like 170 this year you know and I didn't
work every day
so
I've never really worked for anybody
except hospice and I didn't go in half
the time
but you know it's just
I don't know
what I see it's sad to see these girls
all messed up but they don't want help
you can't help them I've tried that you
can't help them so when I give money
don't you don't owe me anything just go
on if you tell me oh yes then you're
gonna owe me and now I'm coming to look
for you you know but rule of thumb
you may love the streets the streets
don't love you and whatever you do
you're going to get caught and so keep
your nose clean keep to yourself stay in
your lane and that's how I've lived and
I have a lot of respect on the streets
but I promise you if I [ __ ] up it's over
you know what I'm saying that I just got
to keep it a difficult transition to go
from the life you had to the life you
have now
um
no I don't know really no
um I guess because like two of my best
friends are of color
and um they live kind of like the ghetto
you know so I've been subjected to that
plus as a hospice nurse I've been
subjected to many things you might see a
beautiful million dollar home and you go
in and it's quarters I've been in the
house where it's gorgeous all the
grounds were Immaculate and go in I'm
sitting at the edge typing on my
computer and something fell from the
ceiling back to my throat back of my uh
shirt it was a mouse I just gotta
started screaming you know but what do
you do I can't leave this lady's dying I
have to finish this you know but and
I've had fleas all over me before they
stripped down outside
just you can't
judge anybody and you can't you know
these people that go in and say I'm
calling you know whoever they can't live
like this where are they going to go
you know that's what I'm so I don't like
do good doers you know what I'm saying
they you come in from your lovely warm
house and you come out here and say I'm
gonna go call you know the authorities
on them because they need help they know
how to get help just leave them alone
what you do is cause problems for them
you know if they want help they'll go
get it and it's just for the glory of
their own not for them really just like
money you know why'd you give that
person this money you know they're using
you because you wanted that money not
because I gave you know it's just one
thing I haven't been able to to get is
the Thief thing they steal from each
other instead of uniting as one on the
street they steal from each other so
I've gotten stolen from a lot like I
left my purse in my room at my own house
go to the bathroom and my money's gone
well that's my own fault because they're
going to come in your room that's not
you know they can do whatever the [ __ ]
they want and they're going to do it so
I've lost a lot of money not thinking
like a thief you know
and I've been put out of stores because
they said I've stolen but I've never
stolen in my life ever a pack of gum
when I was young man I got beat for it
but I don't believe in that you know
and I get everything I want I asked for
and I manifest it meditate on it and it
works for me you know is this are you in
this situation because of your heroin
addiction or is it I'm not in a
situation I go home any day was that
right I'm in a situation of doing this
to myself you know I can go home any day
and my house is just sitting there on I
live um in Madisonville on the river I
have a beautiful home it's not very big
but it's gorgeous it's raised and um my
son wants me to go home but I'm not
ready yet I'm not ready this is my
family now my family is here and
my people are here and I have people
that I take care of here gives me
purpose I don't I'm not going back to
that you know living like that if I go
home I'll probably be recluse you know
stay inside
because I don't have the patience for
ignorant people you know or entitlement
I've had to work hard for my stuff all
my life
and I asked my father when he was dying
daddy why you never gave me any money
when I asked for some he said why do you
think and I said I don't know you gave
Robbie stuff and he said you're smart
he's stupid that's what he told me so I
guess you know he never wanted me to
rely on anybody else but myself
and I did
but I've gotten myself in a lot of
issues with my ex my husband who's dead
he was the monster you know
but we've getting through it you know
day by day how do you compare the
friends you have now to the friends you
had when you were
living they weren't no different they're
really not my friends you know you
really only have a handful of friends
and your closest friends you better
watch too because they're usually the
snake in the garden you know I don't
trust I've trust very few I think I have
like maybe
three people I trust and uh they're all
males I don't you know
people and I'm not mad at anybody for
what they do towards me because
I don't think it's really directed
towards me it's something with them you
know most people if I start yelling at
you and you haven't done anything but
you think it's you it's not it's you
know it's usually my problem and I'm
taking it out on you
um quit being so you know vain to think
everybody's talking about you and and
and wants to do something with you
you're not that you know you're not that
important
you know and
that I find that they're very immature
uh people on the street and around the
people I'm with everything they always
think something's wrong you know and
they're very immature and I guess that's
because
of how they grew up you know they're
very street smart but they're immature
their maturity level I would say is like
from 12 to 16 you know
and fighting is all they know knives
guns you know I carry a gun I do and
I'll use it too I don't have a problem
with it and I know how
um but I don't tell anybody you know but
they show their guns like what are you
doing you know it's just crazy but no
you have to have safety out here you
know at night time I don't go out no why
would I there's nothing but shootings
around me you know
but I'm not scared I'm not ever scared I
don't think I have any fear
the only fear I have is losing another
child that would be my biggest fear
um I'm not afraid to die I had a great
life you know
and I accomplished everything except one
thing I'm going to get my Doctrine in
history that's what I'm working towards
this next fall
and I'm not far off so I'm going to
write grants and do lectures do you see
yourself getting clean from drugs one
day no
maybe I can't answer that question at
this point no no and I'm not going to
rehab I don't care I'm not going you can
put me in jail before I go to rehab I'm
wasting their time as a heroin addict
you could still
um achieve the way you did before
well I was a hospice nurse and nobody
knew for um only five years and I I shot
up but I only took my shot in the
morning and I would come home at lunch
or I'd take it with me if I was far off
you know and nobody knew I shot between
my toes
and I kept it hidden from everybody
for a long time
uh
I guess because I'm lucky that I make a
lot of money and I'll have to steal you
know if I wasn't making the money I did
I probably would have stolen you know
from my family
and I've just been fortunate enough I
would hope that I wouldn't but I
probably would have yeah you want your
fixed you're sick you know but now the
drug
it's not I don't even test out with
heroin or opiates I test out with
nothing
so what is it you know it's not
synthetic all the fentanyl nothing's
real
it's all synthetic do you think you're
addicted to fentanyl now oh absolutely
I've been addicted to fentanyl I would
stick to the fentanyl patches that's
what the doctor gives me not anymore my
doctor knows I do heroin
and uh he doesn't like it when you say
heroin you're you're it's really
familiar uh used to be heroin no it's
it's heroin infant and all mixed you can
get it off the dark web
that's where they're getting it you can
buy anything off of there anything you
want
anything
and I don't understand it but and that's
what a lot of dealers do now
so I don't know
I don't know where I'll be next year I
don't know I don't plan that day to day
tell me about working as a prostitute
I hate it I hate it
um but I don't think about anything but
the money and what I'm gonna do with it
and where it's going to go and if I'm
gonna spend it to get high or am I put
it away who I'm going to give it to or
what I'm going to do but you're
resorting to that even though you have
money stashed away so yeah just to
compartmentalize your life yeah I mean I
I journal every day and write down
everything I want and need I have three
lists what I need what I would like to
have in my wish list you know and
sometimes I get it all I mean I don't do
anything that's outrageous or
ostentatious I stay within my goal but I
do shoot for the stars as far as I can
go with other things with goals that are
further like a year ago plan but I uh do
two week goals I do six week goals you
know monthly goals I have like journals
all over the place I just pick up one
and just start writing
uh it's it's important to me to have all
that and I have I've always been like
that I'm a you know I stay inside I like
to study you know about whatever it is
and I love history now I'm very much
into it
so
I don't know what was the lowest point
of your life losing your signs
it's
ah
you don't understand it
I did everything right I don't
understand it
you know you never let your kids I never
had sitters for my kids I never let them
out my sight
I played I was very hard mother
my son set out as the Gestapo
thank you
my son calls me lady
my youngest son
and he said just listen to the lady and
everything will be good on Friday you
know if they did what I asked it was all
you know they got what we were supposed
to get an allowance I made my kids earn
it I taught my kids I didn't give them a
job unless I did it with them first I
didn't expect them to do anything on
their own here we're gonna do this and
then I'm gonna I'm gonna now you can
take it by yourself you know I was a
fair mother and my kids were my toy them
they're my Playmates I played with them
and we had a lot of fun
but come Sunday at six o'clock it was
over and we're back to the grind you
know it just worked I had five kids I
had a mother and father-in-law in my
house and a drunk husband and a drug
addict and I had houses I was building I
was doing acquisitive prescription
fencing off land I was Finding land a
mortgage broker uh you know pouring
slabs I didn't know what I was doing at
first you know had to learn all that but
it was just like thrown to me thrown in
my lap my husband couldn't finish
nothing
so you know
of course you know I gave up I had sex
with everybody that I got money from you
know of course you know with he was so
jealous but it was hard because he was
so grandiose on everything we had so
many lots and it was like
what are you doing we want to I want to
say small not big I know you know people
understand big is not better small is
great because you have smaller bills
less headaches you know big house you
gotta clean the whole damn thing people
don't use all that house you know that's
just a show thing I've never been like
that the only thing that I've ever
wanted to show is like love is this BMW
like seven series and I had I had one I
just I bought one six months before I
started having seizures and my son took
it and had to sell it because
I can't drive anymore and that's one of
the reasons I came over here too
but yeah my lowest point was
my son the first son and the second son
I just like I can't understand it
at all
and
you know where did I go wrong and is it
my fault
would I do that my son has my karma you
know what I'm saying you know sins of
the father and
it's just I don't understand it but I do
know one thing there is life
we drop our vessel in our bodies and I
believe our soul and our spirit
is still here with us you know
I don't I see I see dead people who I'm
sorry so
um I'm not crazy I've been seeing him
since I was a little girl
and I know there's life after death
and I know there's reincarnation and I
know we've been here together I know
I've met you before it's not coincidence
that people meet you always meet people
for a reason whether it's their reason
or our reason
um I always think it's theirs and so I'm
using mine you know
uh I'm still learning unconditional love
obviously in patience
how patient I was with my patients
wonderful I have no patience whatsoever
nobody either it's like
that's why I can't really be around a
lot of people I just don't understand
just do it you know why do you want to
lollygag around just just do the job you
know but people aren't like me you're an
achiever yeah I want to achieve this so
I can go out and do something you know I
don't want to be working all day I went
off at two you know so I believe getting
up early and handling your business you
know sometimes you have to work late I'm
a workaholic though anyway I always have
my hand in something this isn't the only
thing I do I still uh go in and
restructure businesses and reorganize
people that's what's wrong with most
people is organization you know if
you're looking for your keys for an hour
if you just hung them on the door right
where you're supposed to you would have
found them you know but now you're all
upset and pissed off you know you've
been through so many ups and downs and
lived so many different Lifestyles what
have you learned about life
that maybe most people don't understand
that life isn't guaranteed nothing's
guaranteed and never is
forever is not a word that should be in
the vocabulary
and never also I'll never do this
like you know I don't believe in those
things I believe that
I wish that what I've learned is not to
look back
and only look for today not even look
forward and I could say that because I'm
older but you really have to if you just
do everything right that day tomorrow
will fall into place so don't worry
about it
um we make our own Karma and we have our
karma from the past lives I believe you
know this is just my personal opinion
you know
and
I think that not everybody is to know
everything that we all of us know you
know you might know something more than
me and we do I I
definitely respect my elders because
whether they are as dumb as a box of
rocks or smart they have something to
teach me because they've lived longer
than me here on this Earth so I think
just living day to day and be kind to
others and don't be angry about anything
really because if it's done it's done
just let it go you know and
I just try to live my life happy you
know and
give
to those I don't care if they're drunk
and they're going to go by because I
don't really care because if I'm told
and told to do that I'm giving it to him
you know just follow what you feel in
your heart in your head you know what
your Consciousness is your guides you
know so if you do that you're not going
to steer wrong you know but lessons are
taught by we didn't do wrong we wouldn't
know right if there was no bad it
wouldn't be good so
I thank God for
everything I've been through made me a
strong person
and
I asked every day to bring forth those
who I need to help but sometimes I say
please don't but at least give me a
break and it's not happening you know I
uh give he uses my voice in tongue for
messages to others I never know when I'm
not a psychic or anything I'll take any
Glory it just happens let me be in a
grocery store and say oh that's
embarrassing but always good comes out
if you have something bad that comes out
of a reading then they're not real
there's so many fakes
um I don't take any glory for any of
that but it's it's hard life to live and
we have spirits in their house all day
you know if you had your life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently
never get married
I don't believe in it
but it isn't a white picket fence in
I don't believe that people are I don't
think we are able to be monogamous you
know
and it's okay
you know
um with I have a boyfriend now it took
me 13 years to get one
and uh
I told him you know if you want
something you could just do a lot around
me you know and
I say that you know of course it'll hurt
me and you know if I find it but don't
let me find out or say oh you know
because people hate others to be happy
you know why is it I I'm with him now
and he's with me and everybody's
flocking towards us like trying to [ __ ]
us up it's crazy you know but people
want what they see with us because he's
the only one I see in a room you know
because people are are drawn to that but
that is going to be with you and him or
me with someone else you know I'm not
going to be like that with anybody else
so I think that
I think just stay in your lane and what
I would I wouldn't get married no but
I'd have kids I I you know they're
they're paying but I still love my kids
you know but I I don't want to adopt any
kids you know I don't want anybody
else's problems
but yeah I I would do that
I
guess
I I had a great life
I I mean even though my husband was a
monster it was terrible we laugh about
it now it's nothing to laugh about it's
the only thing we can do me and my son
and he's a monster of my son he is
straight out tell you just how it is you
know sometimes it's genetic sometimes
it's genetic yeah he's my ditto I saw
him he's like we just it's my twin you
know but the personalities are different
than the physical oh he's a monster like
he's just
straight up it's either black or white
you're on this side or that side there
is no in between and you know one day I
said why are you such an ass like I
don't curse in front of him but I said
you're being such an ass and he said ah
like that no no I said why you being
such a jerk he goes apple don't fall far
from the tree you taught me that and you
know I feel I think if I do something I
wouldn't be so hard on my kids you know
second place to me was a loser if you
didn't win first second place the [ __ ] I
don't want that so they made second
place one time and I said oh look you
second place loser they threw it right
in the trash no no that's you said it
was a loser so you know you have to be
careful what you say
do you believe in karma absolutely
absolutely if my Karma's fast like if I
do something if I think something wrong
I'm getting it right away
yeah I try not to do anything
I try not to be bad I mean my Human Side
wants to like sometimes pull somebody's
teeth out you know and just do some bad
things to him but I know that uh
quickly they will destroy themselves you
know what I'm saying
um I have a lot of attackers like people
really attack me a lot because I don't
respond
of things like I just you know walk away
and that pisses people off you know and
I don't give me some money I'm not going
to give you what you know what I'm
saying just there's certain things that
people don't like
they want to bully me I'm a white woman
from Mandeville uppity snob you know but
they learned that I wasn't like that you
had to be careful who the quiet ones are
you know you're existing in a world a
subculture that's very rough it's
extremely rough
but I don't find it to be
I gotta cutthroat no like
I
don't
but I don't put myself out there like
that anymore you know I have certain
people that I see at certain times you
know that I want to you know say hello
to him whatever but I don't go out and
mingle I never have I walk alone I talk
you know I'm just always by myself
unless I'm with my man now I don't do
that you know I don't I stay to myself
that's the best thing to do because
people start too much trouble
and you can get killed like they will
kill you over something so stupid I'm
not going to be that person I've never
been hit beat up or nothing like that so
I'm lucky what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important what what is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
keep your mouth shut
I would say you know
just one word could get someone hurt
or start problems just keep your mouth
you don't know anything you didn't see
anything
and don't offer information
just don't if you know if you're not
involved in that conversation don't say
anything and don't really conversate
about anything you know just keep to
your you know conversate about good
things really it doesn't matter who it
is you can't trust many people
you know and your closest people around
you like I said almost usually the
snakes
don't and it's hard to live that way but
yeah that would be the most important
thing that and um live every day happy
the best you could that's it
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you I hope that helps you